mein name ist luca meine lieben
zuschauer ich habe immer pech im leben
ich weiß noch letztes jahr im karneval
wo ich den coolen slide hinlegen wollte
mir dabei mein steißbein gebrochen habe
heute soll es allerdings nicht um
personen gehen die übelsten pech haben
so wie ich sondern die krasses glück
haben zum beispiel hier
da saß er und hier ist irgendwie eine
dach wellblech plane rein gerannt wer
allerdings gerade schon bei autounfällen
sind schaut euch doch bitte mal diesen
typen ja wie viel glück kannst du haben
oder hier bei der niederrhein gefallen
der elektra wahrscheinlich scheiße drin
das ist einfach sein schlüssel der ist
in einen gully deckel gefallen aber am
gitter hängen geblieben
bild der glücklichen person hat auch
wieder etwas mit einem schlüssel zu tun
und zwar wollte er in einen fahrstuhl
laufen und dabei ist ein schlüssel hier
hängengeblieben und dazwischen ist
einfach der schacht des fahrstuhls das
heißt er hätte den schlüssel
wahrscheinlich nie wieder bekommen dass
hier ganz kurz zwischendurch ist ein
orion mit drei ebenen möbius weil
letztes meinem kumpel einfach zu mir bei
loriots alter die hat sich ja
übertrieben menschen nicht gesund
ziemlich abstoßend gerade schon beim
essen sind das hier ist hat die größte
banane die ich je gesehen habe und
bleibt war direkt bei obst und gemüse
das hier ist glaube ich der kleinste
avocado kern den ich je gesehen habe
kommen wir nun allerdings zu vier
bildern von autos auf die ganz ganz
knapp nur etwas nicht drauf gefallen ist
hier beispielsweise eine laterne und das
auto hat nicht mal einen einzigen
kratzer abbekommen hier beispielsweise
sind vor und hinter das weiße auto
einbauen jeweils hingefallen hier der
baum
hey da braucht man gar nichts mehr zu
sagen hat quasi so eine brücke
geschaffen und hier
der baum ist einfach an der stelle genau
so abgerundet gewesen und hat deswegen
nicht den golf getroffen auf mich willst
du überhaupt darauf fallen wir nicht mal
warum leben wir stehen würde bei dem
bild hier bin ich mir nicht ganz sicher
ob das jetzt glücklich oder unglücklich
ist weil die müssen die tür auch noch
auf machen irgendwie viel glück dabei
auf jeden fall wer allerdings gerade
schon beim thema glück sind und wo ich
auch hier gerade schon ein
das t shirt an habe um mein gott ist das
eine beschissene überleitung heftiges
kleeblatts ich habe mich schon gefreut
wenn ich ein dreirädriges liebert
gefunden habe kommen allerdings nun zu
drei leuten die nur ganz ganz knapp
einer verletzung entgangen sind und zwar
der hier erstmals sind ein nagel
getreten der dann allerdings ein ganz
bisschen an durch die haut gegangen ist
also ich will mir das gar nicht
vorstellen was passiert wenn er da
komplette eingetreten hätte hier genau
das gleiche nur mit einem schuh und hier
hatte die person einfach handschuhe an
und hat dabei etwas an einer kreissäge
geschnitten und das ich glaube dass das
zeigt schon dass hier sollte ein schüler
vögel im wald beobachten und sie dann
halt anhand seines buches zu ordnen und
er hat sich einfach genau der vogel
gesetzen wo er gerade beschrieben wird
ich weiß auch wie es bei mir damals war
in der schule bei mir war es nämlich so
ich hab immer vokabeln gelernt und
einmal hab ich es nicht gemacht und da
kam zwei wochen dabei dieses
eichhörnchen hat es so unfassbares glück
denn direkt über ihm wurde der baum
abgesägt junge das arme kleine ding
alter was hat er zum glück überlebt
hierzu brauche ich glaube ich gar nichts
sagen also der lkw fahrer muss sein
selbstbewusstsein haben alte riese
personen hat den besten spind in der
kompletten schule dann allerdings weiter
mit einer kellnerin die einfach das hier
als tipp bekommen hat wer gibt 90 euro
trinkgeld diese person hier verpacken
und sein eigenes klopapier war leer aber
zum glück ging das von der anderen
toilette daneben so weit runter hattet
ihr das schon mal dass ihr irgendwie zu
hause auf beispielsweise auf dem klo
watt und dann braucht sich die klopapier
und er war nicht und dann so eine halb
herunter gelassener hose durchs ganze
haus gelaufen ich auch nicht jetzt hier
hat einfach seinen zweiten fall genau
den ersten fall reingeworfen zu viel
zielwasser getrunken und diese person
hat sich eine packung trotz gekauft und
hatten nur die roten dort bekommen ich
glaube das ist ein bisschen vergleichbar
mit haribo und da ist zum beispiel bei
mir auch so gewesen dass sich auch am
allerliebsten die roten haare bus
gegessen habe aber es gab auch leute die
dann so meint zum beispiel juli
die mag am liebsten die weißen du bist
anders ticken muss man allerdings nun
auch schon zum letzten bild von einer
überaus glücklichen person und zwar hat
diese person einfach zwei glückskekse in
einer verpackung bekommen
er bekommt zwei glückskeks in einer
verpackung und bei mir stehen jedem
glückspilz gefühl du spielst morgen an
der stelle ich das heute wieder jetzt
allerdings abend meine lieben freunde
wenn euch meine reaktion auf einige der
glücklichsten menschen der welt gefallen
hat das unbedingt einen daumen hoch
unter dem video hier da das wirklich
selbst eine freude und abonniert meinen
kanal falls noch keine helden lupus sei
das ist mich super kostenlose verpasst
keine videos mehr
[Musik]